when you reach the Apex of Esports
competition it is often the finest of
margins that will determine how high you
soar you can spend countless hours
preparing planning and drilling to
execute Perfection but it can all fall
apart cruelly in an instant
the back end of that ultimate figure now
step forward fingernail gets taken out
fake
what was that and while players are
obviously engaged in combat with each
other it's often their own internal
struggles that decide their Fates when
faced with the prospect of devastating
defeat do they succumb to the external
pressure or are they able to calm their
nerves and rise to the occasion the
sound is there the spray is too he's got
a second AKA and he hits bit off the
bomb they have to run him down simples
posted twists you've got no hope
oh
honey
[Applause]
whether it's individual or team based
Esports is and always will be a game of
mental Warfare a grappling match within
one's self that unfolds for all to see a
battle between logic and emotion that
rages within all competitors For Better
or For Worse
shot an absolute disaster but when it
comes to perilously navigating that
internal conflict few competitors have
historically struggled more than Jason
Mewtwo King Zimmerman an OG smash Savant
whose career has been defined by two
things his monstrous melee Mastery this
is why he's saying this is
music King
that quick Zoo to done Wow and his
reputation for tilting off the face of
the Earth and mutual King gives up game
one
I'll be real right now
so how is it that someone who's been
lovingly labeled the robot developed a
reputation as his scene's most
emotionally erratic player how did this
oxymoronic internal conflict become both
his greatest strength and weakness and
why is it that despite not having won a
significant tournament in years Mewtwo
King remains more relevant to smash now
than maybe ever
ah getting pumped right now
okay so before we dive into m2k I'm
gonna ask that you please like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications also be sure to check out
our new twitch offerings over at
twitch.tv slash the score Esports Liz
and I are going live all the time and
we're always looking for more company
alright so if you are even remotely
familiar with smash's competitive scene
you know about Mewtwo King and if you
don't I guarantee that you've at least
seen this incredible picture of him in
your online travels on top of being an
anime loving party game playing machine
Mewtwo King is also a bit of a numbers
guy
7510-58209-749-445986 that's a two
decimals if you don't stop I'm gonna ban
you and while m2k might hold status as a
divinely skilled gamer he has shown that
he's more than capable of committing
some very mortal blunders
no
no
although his status as one of melee's
five Gods was solidified by his spicy
Marth play the truth is m2k is known for
dishing out the heat better than he can
take it
[Music]
but we're not here today to laugh at
Mewtwo King's peculiar tastes or his
history of giving terrible handshakes no
we're gonna explore how he became one of
smash's most influential personalities
and to do that we need to go back all
the way to the early 2000s now from a
very young age it was obvious that
Mewtwo King was something of a gifted
gamer but he didn't actually enjoy
immediate success when it came to
competitive melee although in his
defense before he started attending
actual events he never actually played
against a real person I kind of started
like three years late basically later
than some of the Old Pros have I I did
win some turns in 2005 and I became a
much better throughout the year as I got
more experience in practice from the
outside looking in Mewtwo King appeared
to be your typical smash competitor
obsessed with the game and at times a
bit socially oblivious I was gonna get
first and I you know melee controller
um
but back then what people may have
perceived as typical teenage awkwardness
was more than that because for much of
his life Mewtwo King has been grappling
with Asperger's obsessive compulsive
disorder and ADHD so you would say in
general even though you have had it your
whole life you know you sort of you've
made it work you sort of embraced it
which I like about you yeah I appreciate
about you it's an advantage in terms of
practicing and just focusing on things
and sometimes it could be as I said
disadvantage before noise canceling
headphones but that's again what that
doesn't matter anymore now despite the
obvious challenges that m2k's conditions
presented to him they actually proved to
be something of an asset when shaping
him as a competitor in fact they likely
contributed to his laser-like focus and
determination to just know everything
about melee so before he'd even entered
his first tournament he equipped himself
with an unmatched almost subatomic
understanding of every care character's
Frame data and their strengths and
weaknesses in specific matchups by 2007
Muto King had accrued significantly more
tournament experience and once he paired
that with his profound game knowledge he
became almost Unstoppable oh you have to
be careful against a play like Mitzi
King
eliminated again
destruction he has never been able to
beat Armada but mark your calendars June
1st 2014.
it's over that's it it's over
it's over Future King 3-0 freezes by
leffen just like he breathed by mango
It's Gonna Roll behind it yeah
see one reads it so much pressure
this is a nail biter oh he's off the
ground okay nice wave Dash on the shield
that is that is
he moves on good job Jason Superman from
Cinnamon cinnamonson New Jersey from
2007 to 2015 Mewtwo King was one of
smash's most prolific and highest ranked
players in both melee and brawl he might
not have had the improvisational
artistic style that earned mango his
Legions of followers but his borderline
scientific approach and overall
quirkiness made him an equally beloved
figure in the scene fans respected his
calculated theory-led Styles so much
that they began referring to him as the
robot YouTube King I wasn't really sure
if he would be upset by me calling him a
robot so I just called his episode frame
by frame at that point
[Laughter]
now on the surface this nickname was
aptly chosen
the problem is that
it it wasn't entirely accurate you see
while mutuking had developed a
reputation as a cerebral melee
Mastermind as it turns out his fatal
flaw was that he proved to be at times
overly emotional
should just ordered him what is this
okay what even is happening you didn't
just giving him the stop
yeah mute King looking like uh he
doesn't really care about winning no he
really does not care and the rest yeah
uh I'd be surprised if you just yeah
there we go that's your daughter just
slide these off I always thought that
was a little contradictory because they
called the robot because then on one
hand like that metaphor fails because
he's so human right because he feels and
wears his emotions on his sleeve so much
that's it yep
music okay hey looks like he's about to
cry dude now obviously anyone that's
ever competed in anything has at some
point felt the sting of defeat
but for m2k the losses seemed to hold
a deeper meaning perhaps it was because
he invested so much of himself into
knowing exactly what to do in every
given situation so when things didn't go
exactly as he planned he took it as a
personal failure sometimes I wonder like
who or what he's kind of mad at you know
is he mad at himself he looks exhausted
if he looks exhausted I feel like that
was not only a sigh of like mental you
know give upness but also just like oh
my god I've been here so long and yeah
everything hurts Mewtwo King in essence
was his own worst enemy he had all the
potential to be the best player in the
world but as soon as any doubt began to
creep into his head he was prone to
collapsing like a house of cards some
Personalities in the scene questioned
whether he had it in him anymore While
others criticized his choice to split
his attention between melee and the
subsequent iterations of the franchise
where he was also falling short of his
own lofty standards making matters worse
was the fact that years of Warring on
land started to take a toll on m2k's
body only adding to the doubts he was
having about his competitive future I
know how good he is
I do know his flaws but he have so many
strengths that he could use to his
Advantage but it makes me sad that
regardless of how many things he has in
his favor he has to be obsessed about
the one thing that might be not good
right now now here's the thing though in
spite of all the challenges he faced
Mutual King was still an elite level
competitor who routinely finished top 8
at events he attended the biggest knock
against him was that he hadn't won a
Super major since 2007 and the last
tournament he won with at least three
gods in attendance was in 2016. although
his path somehow never crossed mango or
hungrybox the entire bracket but Mutual
King had the chance to put that
unfortunate skid to an end in early 2018
at smash Summit 6 where all of melee's
top active players would be present the
stage was set for Mewtwo King to answer
his critics and did he ever okay
he was looking
[Music]
he didn't waste no time
I asked for the platform oh that's a big
back here
[Music]
doesn't get anything off of it oh and
Mewtwo kid there it is wow
[Music]
dunk dude really well m2k is looking
like he's ready to do it man let's see
if you can keep it together yeah yeah I
think this is that's what decides this
all right I got some decent damage
oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
although even Mewtwo King was clearly
Blown Away by his Monumental Triumph at
smash Summit six at the time fans
couldn't have known that it would be his
last major win after 2018 it became
clear that his motivation to compete in
singles had all but gone in the years
since he's entered fewer and fewer
tournaments in both melee and ultimate a
far cry from his days as esports's most
active competitor but for someone who'd
practically dedicated their entire life
to smash he simply couldn't walk away
from it all together so instead of
choosing to battle it out with the
rising crop of up-and-coming talent he
decided instead to bestow his knowledge
upon them as a coach this is a space
exotic stuff not Ken specifically But
Ken release fams of cybian neutral he
doesn't play a ground game much like he
doesn't do a lot of running Shield or
running ground moves he mainly just
relies on the side V so he just makes a
up the 50 50 of starting side and then
doing Shield or starting side B and then
moving into them to have somebody Mentor
you who's been around for you know at
this point Mutual King's been competing
17 years or something so
um that kind of experience in your
corner definitely helps now obviously
there's no denying that over his
decades-long competitive career Mewtwo
King has contributed so much to smash
but the truth is that the games have
given him just as much in return he
appeared on the scene as a quiet lonely
kid from a small town in New Jersey but
by attending countless events he formed
friendships that not only helped him to
feel like an important part of a larger
Community but also more comfortable in
his own skin of course Mewtwo King still
retains his signature Charming
awkwardness and he likely always will
but today he's confident enough in who
he has become that he's now willing to
share more of his personality with
people than ever before what's up
scrambled eggs
how do you like your eggs
how do you like your eggs well you know
what I wasn't the one whose boobs
magically grew a size bigger as soon as
Jason started showing up
wait does that happen with girls
what oh what the heck what
what
and if watching him goofing around on
stream or breaking down smash with his
friends isn't enough m2k for you he's
also been working on an autobiography in
the background I don't know when the
final products can be released I don't
really know I do hope that people would
consider supporting it when it comes out
it's been 84 years it's not entirely
clear what the future will bring for
smash's Royal robot for now he seems
happy creating content and engaging in
every possible discussion there is
surrounding the franchise and Wallace
fans might hang on to the hope that one
day the king will once again return for
his crown the truth is he doesn't feel
like he needs to I don't really have any
immediate plans and also I'm not really
concerned with that because I've already
proved myself for so many years at the
end of the day Mewtwo King's Journey
serves as a reminder that the
relationships between Esports
competitors and their games can be
beneficial in more than a financial way
through his incredible highs and
heartbreaking lows he's become a fixture
in a community that he continues to help
shape a scene that didn't just accept
him for being who he is but celebrated
him for it I just really love the way
that him and the community kind of grew
together and now he's in this position
where he's helping out everyone else m2k
is living breathing proof that you can
have a successful career in Esports
without being forced to choose between
logic and emotion that in the Quest for
gaming immortality sometimes showing
your humanity is what can truly turn you
into a God m2k is playing with fire
right now oh man
up here
has taken out the number one player in
the world
what is happening this is
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it's funny my opinion on Smash
has changed a lot over the years I was
watching Evo this past weekend with the
co-stream I was thinking to myself like
we need melee back anymore like I I we
really do I was watching Mango's big
house run coincidentally like two weeks
ago again I was watching him do the run
and that final against Zayn I don't know
man there's something about the way that
that smash players love melee that is
like really special we I miss melee like
I miss it